- Hello, good morning.
And thank you for
joining for this session.
I hope you all are having a lovely day too
and are already raking up a lot of steps,
walking through the maze
that this conference is,
but I hope that you continue to have fun
and a lot of learning
for the rest of the week.
My name is Sujay Doshi
and I'm a senior product
manager with Amazon GuardDuty.
I'll be completing four
years this February,
and I'm joined today
by Peter and Mikaelly.
- Hi, Peter Ferrie.
I've been with Amazon for
five and a half years.
And this year is my 40th year
in doing anti-malware research.
- Thank you, I'm Mikaelly.
I'm in Nubank in almost three years
and I'm working as a
senior security engineer.
- All right, thank you.
So quick agenda, we'll start
with giving a short overview
of what the service is.
Just raise of hands on how
many of you today use GuardDuty
and more specifically
one of the malware protection offerings.
All right, okay, that's good.
Next we'll talk about the new
features that we launched,
a couple of new features that
we launched a few weeks ago.
One is a scan on-demand API
and the other is a fully managed offering
to scan your AWS Backups from malware.
Next, we'll use Peter's
extensive experience,
and then for the first time,
he'll actually dive deep
into the inner workings
of the GuardDuty malware scan engine
and essentially how we keep up
with the ever-evolving malware landscape.
And then, we'll have Mikaelly share
on how they use one of the offerings
or couple of the offerings
from malware protection
from GuardDuty to drive their
security outcomes at Nubank.
So GuardDuty, Amazon GuardDuty,
for the ones that do not know,
it's a native threat
detection service from AWS
trusted by 95% of our
top 2000 AWS customers
looking at data and consuming logs.
Essentially, GuardDuty for
across tens of thousands
of customers monitors hundreds
of millions of EC2 instances
and millions of S3 buckets
to essentially give
visibility into account
and resource level compromise.
The sophistication that it derives
is the accessibility to
native threat intelligence
that it collects from various
internal threat intel groups
and combining it with all the
different detection algorithms
that we use that threat intelligence
to detect sophisticated cloud threats.
One such example is with
a system called Mithra
that we run internally.
It's a domain reputation service.
It's a graph-based neural network database
that essentially monitors all
the DNS traffic across Amazon
for the last seven days
and curates a list of
malicious and benign domains,
a lot of the times, days, weeks, months,
sooner than a traditional
threat intel provider.
And the reason we are able to
do this is the accessibility
and the telemetry that we are looking at
to kind of build this intelligence.
Being a fully managed service
and being the first-party service,
automatically these IOCs in form of IPs,
domains and file hashes are consumed
by GuardDuty into the threat
intelligence platform,
that is then used to monitor
the customer workloads
and the network traffic
to detect those threats.
The other example that we share here
would be a system called MadPot.
That's a globally distributed
system of threat sensors,
honeypots that's essentially
tracking the attacker behavior,
the tactics, the techniques
and the procedures,
which ultimately also provides us the IOCs
and the behavior to understand
on how the attackers are
targeting the whole of AWS cloud
that we can then leverage for
specific customer workloads
and then use it to generate findings.
And then from an elasticity perspective
or the auto-scaling aspect,
we are just sharing an anecdote
that this year during Prime Day,
which I hope a lot of
you were able to enjoy,
GuardDuty processed close to
9 trillion events in an hour,
goes on to show with the
49% increase year-over-year
on how automatically it will scale
with the data that it consumes.
With all this intelligence,
it essentially relies on the telemetry
and the sources that we
collect the data from.
When you think about GuardDuty
as an account that has enabled GuardDuty,
automatically will be monitoring
the cloud trend management
events and the VPC flow logs
and the DNS query logs
from your EC2 instances.
That's basically what we
call as foundational sources.
And then everything else that we have,
S3 data plane events, Lambda monitoring,
when we monitor the
Lambda function executions
for network threats, all of
this, in the runtime agent,
all of this essentially are what we call
as operating protection plans.
So as a delegated
administrator, you can decide
to enable it on specific
workloads where you pertain
that the threat activity would manifest
and you want to be protected against.
Once we collect all of this
data, and a key differentiator
from a fully managed
aspect perspective means
that US customers, you do not need
to do any source service
side configuration
and then collect the data
so that we can process it.
You don't need to, you know,
collect the data
specifically for GuardDuty.
It may be for any investigation
or compliance purposes,
but GuardDuty does not rely
on customer vended logs.
If you enable one feature
or multiple of these features,
we'll automatically pull the
data from a backend stream
so that you do not have
the cost of ownership
of collecting the data and then, you know,
shipping it to GuardDuty
so that we can process it.
And that's a key value proposition,
being the first-party in
a fully planned service.
Once we have all of this data,
it goes to the analytics engine
that essentially comprises
of threat intelligence.
We talked about some heuristics-based
TTB detection algorithms,
and then we also learn
the normal behavior from these logs
to essentially generate ML-based
anomaly detection findings
that gives visibility from the perspective
of is it normal for the organization,
is it normal for this particular workload?
Does the communication happen from an ASL
that has bad reputation,
so on and so forth.
But the major focus of
this session would be
on malware scanning or malware detection.
Historically, when GuardDuty
was launched in 2017
and up until 2022,
we had all of these
different protection plans
or features which relied on
telemetry data or events.
But in 2022, for the first time,
we expanded to scan a particular resource
specifically here to detect malware.
So we'll talk about some of the offerings
for malware protection that we have.
Starting with in 2022, as I said,
we launched for the first
time malware protection
for EC2 that delivers
an agentless solution
to detect malware for your
EC2 and container workloads
that have been attached to EBS volume.
With a single click, and similar
to other features, right?
The ease of use and holistic coverage
across the organization remains paramount.
With a single click, you can
get malware protection coverage
for all your accounts and workloads.
The centralized monitoring,
so you'll have a delegated administrator
and the security teams can
essentially review the findings
with contextual data
around the malware family,
the source within the
scan engine that we use,
and we'll talk about that
later in the session.
A very big value proposition
here is that there's no agents.
So you don't have to update, manage,
install in order to
specifically detect malware.
The container awareness
brings in a key protection
against some of your
container deployments.
And if there's a malware that's installed,
prior to this feature,
customers had to essentially
take a snapshot of their volumes,
run it against whatever malware scanner
is at their disposal, and
then try to stitch it back
to a narrative around,
if you saw in GuardDuty,
a network anomaly that indicates
that there's some
communication to C2 server,
what would a customer want to do, right?
They'll take a snapshot,
they'll check whether that's malware
or whether a malware was
installed as a result
of this network communication.
But all of that with this feature
was automated with a single click.
So customers who have enabled this feature
automatically will have
their EBS volume scanned
when we see a preceding network anomaly.
Or you can even use scan on-demand
as part of your investigation
or forensics workflow.
And then there's no performance impact
to your live workloads, 'cause again,
there's no agents that are installed.
Next we expanded the offering to provide
a fully managed solution to
secure the data pipelines
that you build on S3,
specifically helping to solve
for untrusted upload
application use cases.
You have external vendors
that's uploading data
or you have internal users
that's uploading data to S3.
In both this scenarios,
you did not first want to
be the receiver of something
that's malicious so that
you want to establish
a trustworthiness in the data
that's uploaded to your S3.
And also in the second case,
you do not want your internal users
through some later
supply chain compromise,
in the event that they're uploading,
let's say, an image file,
it's actually not a malware
and you do not want to be
a distributor of malware.
In both these cases, there's
a massive need to ensure
that there's trustworthiness in the data
and you can trust the prominence
of the data that's being sent.
With this feature on the buckets,
you can configure the
malware protection plan,
and we'll automatically monitor
for any new objects that are uploaded.
We'll scan them, we'll detect
if it's a malware generative finding,
using EventBridge, there'll
be scan notification
that you can consume
either in the delegated
administrator account
or your bucket owner
or the member accounts.
But once we also complete the scan,
we'll attach a tag on the object itself
so that you can implement
inherent protection
and quarantine use cases.
Using tag-based access control
in the bucket policy, you
can ensure that no user
of the application can
access this particular object
until and unless you find a
tag that's clean, let's say.
The scan engine, and
again, we'll dive deeper
into what all comprises
within the scan engine,
but that's automatically updated
to keep up with the signatures
and detection definitions
that we'll be using to detect malware.
So as a customer, you don't need
to manage the infrastructure.
There's no management of
updating the scan engine
to keep up with the latest
and the greatest threats.
And all of it is managed
on your behalf through this feature
and the seamless setup with
your minimal configuration
on the buckets that you want to protect
from unprecedented upload applications.
Few weeks ago, we expanded
the same offering.
Everything's the same
from a scan infrastructure perspective.
You do not need to manage, again,
no infrastructure, no scan engine updates.
But we added another pattern
essentially to ensure
that you not only scan any new
object uploads for malware,
but you can decide to
even scan existing objects
within an S3 bucket to
actually detect malware.
And you can seamlessly
integrate into your workflows
using the API to ensure
that even for the optics
that are already existing,
you can establish a security
baseline for the buckets
that are, let's say, not newly set up.
And a hybrid strategy
of combining continuous monitoring
through new object upload scanning
and then retro scanning through objects
that are already present in your S3 bucket
to ensure that you have the latest
and the greatest security
baseline for the buckets
that's in that untrusted upload realm.
And again, the orchestration layer,
you can use the API depending
on what the operating procedures are
and the workflow entails.
A major focus of this session
for the remaining part of
at least my talk would be
to introduce the fully managed offering
that we expanded in GuardDuty
malware protection suite
of offerings, is to scan the backups taken
by AWS Backup for malware.
We launched this a few weeks ago,
and this is where from
the AWS Backup console,
as part of your backup plan,
you can ensure continuous monitoring
for malware once a backup job completes.
We'll scan your EBS backups
or snapshots, your EC2 AMIs
and your S3 recovery points
automatically for malware
once you set up that configuration
as part of your backup plan.
You can also use on-demand scanning
and investigate your past backups,
very specifically useful for
safe restoration workflows.
In addition to the
scanning, we have two modes
that are available, full and incremental.
Incremental scanning here
provides cost efficiency
wherein will only scan for the data
that's changed between a
backup that I took yesterday
and the backup that I'm scanning today.
So you don't end up paying
for the entire scan always,
but then the full scan
is where you add more security assurance,
and it's something that
you would want to ensure
that you're safely restoring always
with the latest
verification from the latest
and the greatest malware
detection definitions.
So the full scan gives
you that opportunity.
And again, the idea is
it does not involve you
as part of the backup processes.
So the backup jobs, once they are complete
is when the scan initiates,
and there's minimal configuration
that you have to do either on GuardDuty
or backup to realize this feature.
And this eliminates the need
for you to do manual scan
and restore workflows,
which are time-consuming,
delays the business recovery
in cases on events like ransomware
and provides you a seamless integration
between these two kind
of native AWS services.
But you might ask
on why would you scan
backup resources for malware
if you're already scanning
the live workloads
either through traditional EDR tools
or using one of the
offerings from GuardDuty
that we talked for EBS volume scanning
and your S3 object scanning?
And to understand this,
we'll try to look at a scenario
on how a malware progresses
through a backup.
And this timeline is a typical
14-day retention timeline
wherein each block
represents a daily backup.
So as you can see in the first phase,
which is the green phase,
from day one to seven,
we see that the attacker
already has a foothold
in the environment.
But again, the malware was planted,
but it's dormant, it's
not yet activated, right?
We don't see any system changes,
there's no files that are impacted.
We don't see encryption,
or there's no malicious artifacts
that got introduced in day one to seven.
Also, the dormancy of the malware ensures
that there's no persistence that's created
and it's just specific malware files
that are present, but
they're not yet acting upon.
Also the reason we call these
backups as clean backups
is in a typical restoration workflow,
you'll restore, you'll always restore
or you want to restore in a
clean and isolated environment.
What that does is it
actually, in many cases,
negates the effect of the malware,
which is environment dependent, right?
And it also blocks the C2
communication pathways.
So all in all, this represents
the safe recovery period
and also a point in time
before malicious behavior
is surfaced in the environment.
The second phase is the
yellow phase, day 8 to 10,
where we start seeing early
stage artifacts appearing
in the environment.
This might be small preparatory changes
but are still low noise that
in environment, EDR tools
or live scanning workload solutions,
will actually not have
noticeable indicators
that are generated 'cause of the low noise
and still the dormancy of the malware.
But all of these, once
the malware's activated,
actually that slips past into the backups.
You can still do some surgical
fixes from these malware
and restore just the
critical business data.
But that is where you
still need to perform
the item level recovery capability
that AWS Backup inherently
provides, ensuring that
you are restoring just the
clean portion of these backups.
And day 11 to 14 represents
where we see ransomware event happen.
So the entire production system
and even your new backups
that are taken are
actually all compromised,
and it's unsafe to restore
from these backups.
If you think about this
timeline in a real environment,
the timing spans across multiple weeks.
For an example, if the initial compromise
that we talked about
happened three weeks ago,
your last clean backup that you know of
was taken two weeks ago.
The activation happens now.
So imagine that by the
time the team identifies
that there's a breach
in their environment,
it might be too late because
of the retention window
that you typically would have
configured for your backups
and you start losing on the clean backups.
Imagine if you identify the
breach one week from now,
you're basically losing out
on the entire safe recovery window
or the backups that are identified
and tagged as clean backups.
So the key takeaway here
is proactive preservation
of the clean backups,
but more importantly, identification
that you have a clean
or an infected backup
to ensure that your recovery process
in the event of events like ransomware,
you can safely recover
always from a clean copy.
So this progression actually highlights
a natural blind spot and
the early stage threats
that slip past into the
backups but are not detected
by live workload scanning solutions
like GuardDuty, EBS
scanning or S3 scanning,
or even your traditional EDR tools,
'cause they are not designed
to actually detect some of
these dormant behaviors.
They'll be monitoring the in
environment running workloads.
And then we look at the
behavior in many cases
to find something malicious has happened.
And if the threat is dormant,
which in our example was the case,
these threats will slip
past into the backup.
Automatic backup scanning
essentially solves
or addresses this by continuously scanning
the backup data addressed
into the backup repositories,
abstracting vault level constructs,
so that it automatically,
once the backup job completes,
will initiate the scan.
And it continuously tracks the changes
that happens to your backups
and identifying from when a backup moved
from clean state to unsafe
to actually compromised.
And then you can define
the last known clean backup
is what you want to restore
from in the event of ransomware.
Also, the traditional recovery
solutions actually rely
on manual restore and
scan, which is again,
as we identified, is
time-consuming, adds cost overhead
and delays essentially
the business recovery.
So automatic scanning through this feature
basically solves for these efficiencies
and will continuously provide assurance
of the presence of malware
as the backups are taken.
All in all, bringing this together,
backup scanning essentially
provides a second layer
of defense to your
traditional malware scanning
for live workload solutions.
And hence, they are
more like complementary
and not competing solutions,
which are two essential security layers
in the entire data protection life cycle.
Quickly, we'll look into, you know,
the importance of periodic full scan
and how you want to ensure
that while cost efficiency
is a major factor with
incremental scanning,
but time and again, and
especially for safe restoration,
how full scan and more
specifically periodic full scans
are important, right?
So imagine the first full scan happens
on the day one when the backup runs.
So day one to four,
after the first backup,
there's incremental scan,
and we'll continue to scan
just the data that changed
between these days.
Let's say a malware, a
zero-day malware was planted
on day four, but GuardDuty,
because at that point,
the detection definitions
did not have information
about that threat.
So what we'll do, when we
will do incremental scan,
we'll actually tag it as no threats found.
Even though the threat
exists in the backup,
when we scan that data,
because we didn't have
the detection definitions,
we'll tag it as no threats.
So now let's say after the fifth day
is when the malware engine was updated
and we now have that information
of the zero-day malware.
But if you continue to
just run incremental scans,
because it only scans the data
that's different from the past
day, we'll actually continue
to attach the wrong disposition
to subsequent backups
and we'll continue to tag
them as no threats found.
So where periodic full
scans come into play,
for the same scenario on the day six
when we identify that
there is no threats found,
let's say on day seven, you
actually ran a full scan.
Now because you already
have the information
with the latest detection definition
and also the definition
for the zero-day malware,
we'll actually attach
the right disposition.
We'll say that backup
seven, it has threats
and we'll also maintain the lineage
of all the backups attached,
or the parent backup from within,
we continue to take incremental backups.
So once you rebased the baseline
through periodic full scan,
when we do an incremental
scan on the eighth day,
even though there's no
new file that was added,
which was actually malicious,
we carried forward the status.
So tomorrow, if you
decide to actually restore
from eighth day backup, you
will have the information
that in the lineage, there was a backup
that was either the same backup
or the backup in the lineage has malware.
So once you remove that malicious file
from the backup source,
subsequent incremental scan
automatically will re-base the status.
So now what this provides is
is it maintains the
information and the history of,
through incremental scans,
it will maintain the history
of what files that were
detected as malware,
are they still malicious?
And if they are, we continue
to carry forward the status.
And if we don't find that malicious file
and everything is clean,
we'll update the status
so customers can use
the subsequent backups
or the last known clean backup.
This is the importance
of periodic scanning
to ensure assurance every
time you wanna restore.
A sample implementation workflow.
Think about using GuardDuty,
you get to the point
where there's an outcome
in form of findings,
there is EventBridge notification.
You can use that and have
custom implementation
through a Lambda function later
that will tag the backups
and use SCP to ensure
that you are never restoring from a backup
that's tagged as infected.
On the other hand, for clean backups,
you can safely move them
to an isolated environment
to ensure that you always restore
from these isolated
logically air-gapped vaults
to make sure that the backups
you're restoring is safe.
How it looks on the console?
You simply provide a scanner rule
as part of your backup
plan, define which resources
you want to perform the
backup scanning for,
and then you select the
mode against the cadence
of daily, hourly, weekly, monthly.
And then the on-demand
scanning is exactly the same.
When you provide for
investigation on forensics,
you provide and you can
perform full on incremental,
but you provide the on
and we'll continue to scan
providing you have the right
permissions given in the rule.
And then on GuardDuty, you
can monitor the results.
Again, contextualization,
like any other finding
in GuardDuty, is paramount,
will give them malware source information,
the scan engine information,
so on and so forth.
And again, if you wanna restore
as part of your backup processes,
you go to the backup console
and then you look at the
backups that are clean.
And then you can define
to either run an on-demand scan view,
we actually recommend to
run an on-demand scan always
at the time you are restoring
so that it verifies against
the latest signature set
to give you the assurance that you need.
Pricing, straightforward pricing
for all the resource types.
That is EBS, S3 and EC2, $0.05 for the GB.
If you decide to do incremental scanning,
the first scan will
certainly be a full scan
so that we can then define
on the next time a backup
is run, what has changed.
But the first scan will be full
and then subsequent will be incremental
depending on your configuration.
And there's an example, for
100 GB volume, it'll be $5.
And then subsequently, if
there's only 2 GBs that changed,
you know, it'll be cost-efficient,
giving you kind of the same
results that you'd reach to
or outcomes you'd reach
to with full scans.
So some general best practices.
Automated incremental
scanning for cost efficiency,
periodic full scans for
re-base lining and assurance.
And like I said, in time
of security incidents
for restoration, on-demand
scan's always appreciated.
And you don't need to enable
foundational GuardDuty,
but we still recommend it, right?
Think of different solution
and findings that we have,
especially for resiliency
and recovery and ransomware detections,
which is not always based on files
but file list behavior
you see with, you know,
S3 data plane events where
we see a lot of encryption
through customer keys, or there's a spike,
a anomalous spike in, you know,
GetObject, ListObject kind of scenarios.
All of those signals and
findings are available
in GuardDuty through other features.
So even though foundational
guard, it is not paramount,
but we recommend it so
that you can combine it
with these signals to get
higher fidelity findings
around your ransomware events.
And with all the information
that's available in
findings and EventBridge,
both backup persona and security persona
get the relevant information
around the malware.
AlL right, I'd like to
invite Peter to talk
and dive deep into this.
- So GuardDuty has multiple
engines that it uses
to handle different detection scenarios.
The first engine we have
is a hash-based one,
and we use that engine primarily
to suppress false positives
so we can exclude the
one file and no others.
We also use this engine
for responding quickly.
For example, if there's an outbreak
and we can add detection very quickly,
and we can respond within
minutes instead of hours.
The engine itself is quite fast.
We found some ways to accelerate
our hashing operation.
And the engine itself is resilient
to minor changes in the file.
And what I mean by that is that typically,
we consider a file to be
a solid block of bytes,
and so hash just from end
to end to get a single hash.
But there can be cases where a file has a,
instead of being a solid block of bytes,
there might be some squishy
bit right in the middle.
It might have a URL or
username/password combination.
And in that case, our engine is differing
from the traditional implementation,
because it can be told to
hash around the variable part.
Similarly, if a file has content
at the end that is variable,
perhaps there's an appended configuration,
then our engine can be told
to hash up to the point
where the variable content starts,
which means that you can add
any number of additional bytes,
you can change any values
within the variable section
and we'll still have a constant hash.
So for the people that,
you know, bad actors
that are getting their
sites taken down quickly
and they keep cycling, we'll
still have detection for these.
The next engine we have is
a pattern matching engine.
In the event that hashing is not suitable
because there might be multiple
changes throughout the file,
or if a file is very, very large,
but the really interesting
part is right at the front,
then we'll use the pattern
matching engine for that.
The engine is very flexible,
it supports traditional
signature-based scanning,
just doing straight byte comparisons.
But we can do more than that.
We can perform conditional evaluations
up to a certain point in the file.
We can perform frequency analysis
of the bytes we've seen
up to a certain point,
and we can even extract
bit level characteristics
of the file for very fine
grain pattern matching.
The engine is very expressive,
so the intent of a detection
is very clear for the next engineer
who has to perhaps extend
an existing detection
or if they're the ones
having to do the code review
for an existing detection.
We use this engine primarily
for specific detections
where the code is constant
across replicants.
And here's an example from actual malware.
This code will execute arbitrary
commands received remotely
without any user interaction.
And for us, this quite a simple example.
It's a single detection,
but there also can be cases
where we wanna use the
engine for generic detections
where multiple variants of the same sample
differ only slightly, but
otherwise functionally equivalent.
Here's an example of an actual malware,
just a snippet of the code.
This malware uses a polymorphic engine
to change its appearance
from replicant to replicant.
And the engine is able to
insert random characters
in the decryptor body
and also change the variable
names to random strings.
Here's another example where you can see
the constant portions
are becoming smaller.
And here's the extreme example
where the constant
portions have been reduced
to the smallest possible length
and all the variable names
have been replaced with random strings.
And despite the difference
between the first example
and the last one, it's still
a single detection for us.
That gives a sense of just
how powerful this engine is.
The next engine we have is
a machine learning engine,
and our focus with machine learning
is cryptocurrency miners.
The reason for that is because
within our environment,
cryptocurrency miners are a big problem.
And you might be wondering
how big of a problem it is.
If we look at this table here, we can see
how quickly a cryptocurrency
miner can be installed.
We went from a misconfigured state
to a compromised state in less
than four and a half days,
which means that the
compromised instance was found
in its pristine state almost immediately
and the miner was installed
very, very quickly after that.
If we consider from a dynamic
analysis point of view,
over 60% of compromised workloads
involve cryptocurrency mining
as part of that post exploitation event.
And in fact, cryptocurrency mining
is the most common post
compromise activity
that we see in a dynamic
detection scenario.
But coming back to the static analysis,
I took one week's worth of scan
results that had detections.
Of those scan results,
I took 8,000 samples entirely randomly.
And of those 8,000 detections we had,
45% of them were cryptocurrency miners.
Now not all of those were unique,
but even if 90% of them were identical,
that still leaves over 300 unique samples
that someone would have to
add detection for manually
from this subset week-over-week,
if we were to do this one at a time.
So that's a huge problem.
But fortunately for us, we
have a machine learning model,
and I would love to say it's so awesome
that it detects all of these,
but it's not, at least not yet,
but still, it's doing some
very heavy lifting for us,
and for the ones that it doesn't detect,
we have our patent matching engine
and the hashing engine
to clean up the rest.
The next engine we have
is a third-party engine.
We receive this engine as
an SDK from the vendor,
and it runs as part of
our regular scan flow.
But we run this engine in an
entirely isolated instance.
It's not able to connect
with the cloud provider,
it's not able to connect
to the internet at all.
The only thing we get out of the instance
is the finding results, and
we are very careful about
what we will accept
from the finding results
to minimize the chance
of exfiltration of data.
We use this engine primarily
for historical detections,
because the vendor has seen many samples
that we might never see.
We don't automatically
collect samples from customers
and we don't share these
samples with the vendor.
So in the event that a
customer is not willing
to share a sample with us,
then we might never see the sample at all.
The SDK also offers heuristic detections,
and they use a machine learning
model for this as well.
We are working to develop
our own heuristics specific
to our environment, but at least for now,
these existing heuristics
are a very powerful baseline for us.
We also get passes in this
SDK for common file formats
such as archives, images and documents.
Again, we're working on
our own passes specific
to our environment to get
better scanning performance,
but we also have file formats
that the vendor might never see
because we don't share the samples.
And so we're working on
specific parsers for those two.
So that covers our static
detection for EC2 and S3.
And Mikaelly, my co-presenter,
will talk more about a
specific use case for S3,
but we have more than
just static scanning.
We also have a runtime service.
This runtime service runs on the instance.
It has system-wide
visibility into everything
that's happening as it happens.
We get file system and network events,
and there's also container aware,
so we can see inside AKS and ECS.
We collect events from
the system into signals
and a collection of signals
get correlated into a finding.
Here's an example of a finding
using our latest extended
threat detection,
which was presented at an
earlier talk this morning.
You can see the level of
detail that we have here.
We have a detection here
for a newly downloaded file.
There was a file system event
when the file was downloaded
that triggered a hash
calculation and a hash lookup.
The hash was found on our deny list
and resulted in this finding.
Here's what the findings
used to look like,
and you can see what we changed it.
If you squint to the
top right-hand corner,
you can see a reverse shell
was created on the system.
We have file system events
when the file was created.
We had the system event when
the process was started,
and we have the network events
when the process connected
to the website and when it
redirected the standard IO
to point to particular port on the system.
And that collection of events
resulted in this finding.
Here we have another detection for a site
that tried to connect to
a cryptocurrency website.
And the network event that was intercepted
when the process attempted
to connect to the site
is what resulted in this finding.
But for customers that don't want to run
a runtime service on their instance,
we have a network level scanning as well.
And this is not relying
on explicit scanning,
it is just monitoring the
activity as it happens.
The network scanning is able to watch
for network connections to
sites with poor reputation.
It's able to detect credential use
in anomalous configurations,
and it's also looking for data access
that is not within the
typical behavior patterns
on the system.
Used an example of a finding
where a instance tried
to connect to a cryptocurrency website.
Used an example of a finding
where an instance tried
to connect to a command
and control website.
And finally, here is a finding
where an IP address that's
on our deny list attempted
to call an API that is
commonly used just prior
to an exploitation attempt.
This shows how all of
our engines work together
to protect customers
and that's how we keep up
with the threat landscape.
And now I'll pass to Mikaelly
who can describe a
specific use case for S3.
- Thank you, Pete.
So I'm from Nubank's cloud security team,
and I'm gonna present use case from EC2
and history of GuardDuty's malware module.
But before this, let me
start introducing us to you.
Nubank was born from the discomfort
and the powerless feeling while dealing
with bureaucracy in financial services.
We started in 2013 in Brazil with a goal
of simplifying people's lives
and empowering them financially.
Since 2013 to today, we went
from a credit card issuer
to the most valuable brand in the country.
Seeing how successful we were,
we begin to search another markets,
and seeing how similar
problems Latin America have,
we started that, and now we have presence
in three countries in
Mexico, Columbia, in Brazil.
We surpass our 100 million clients goal,
and we still managed to have a metric
of customer-centered philosophy
to have less than $1 cost
to serve each client.
About the challenge they
are gonna present here.
As Nubank was scaling
and adding more financial
products in more countries,
we begin to have a
problem with rapid growth
and also different (speaks indistinctly)
with specific countries.
And this year, we had the opportunity
to have a single process for PCI,
because it's basically
the same in each country.
The main point about the PCI
that I'm going to present here
is about malware detection,
and not only about the requirements
that we were gonna attend,
we also had the company's requirements.
Our security team don't have to impact
or add friction to growth.
So we were searching a tool
that could be effortless
to integrate in our system,
and GuardDuty was the smoothest
and most integrated with our environment.
To begin the implementation strategy,
I have a main point to present here,
is Nubank, in Nubank,
we treat each country
as a single organization in AWS.
So if we're gonna do the configuration
of GuardDuty on AWS organizations,
we would have administration
points for each country.
And as a global team, it's simpler
to go into with a
invitation-based implementation.
It showed on the step three.
But in practice, we have the accounts
with the resource in the original place.
And going further to our
administration point.
For the monitoring of
findings, we have a dual path.
As a cloud security team,
we have to enable things
from other security teams
and have this monitoring constantly.
The main path and the official path
for the certain SOC teams
for incident response
is the one that goes through a bucket
and feeds our CM so they can interact.
And the other path serves
up our purpose of visibility
and also that we can be promptly ready
to have any assistance
for the security teams
and the production teams
invited in the incident.
Beyond the implementation
of the detection,
we also managed to get ready
specifically for history.
The whole process automated
with a first response
where we can be a tech-based pipeline.
Once GuardDuty tags a S3 object,
we manage to have a restrictive policy.
So only SOC teams have
interacting with the file
and have the analysis.
If they matched false positives,
they also update and the
access is head storage.
For the EC2, we went from a
more conservative approach,
because in automated first
response could lead to outage.
So we made available the
isolation in the playbook,
but it's only applied once the team
is involved in the incident.
So to finalize our use of GuardDuty,
what we begin with regulated request,
we managed to revise our process
of malware analysis in Nubank
and also improve the process.
Because we use GuardDuty
in our already integrated environment,
we cause no disruption
to productive teams.
We didn't break anything
and it was very seamless.
We also achieve a global compliance,
and we can rollout to any
country that we intend to.
This changed completely
our coverage in the cloud
because we didn't have this two history.
And also by enabling this,
we managed to get to productive teams.
A new feature, they can autonomous enable
a document triage for third-party
files and be more secure.
The whole process was revised
and enabled in less than two months,
and we still manage to
maintain the cost less than $1
to serve each account.
So welcome back.
Sujay, finalize.
- Thanks, Mikaelly.
All right, so some key takeaways
from this session that we learned.
The fully-managed aspect
reduces the cost of ownership
for you to detect threats from
malware in your workloads,
and more specifically aiding
in ransomware scenarios
with the recently launched feature.
And again, put live workloads
and you can combine now
with backup scanning,
or for backup workloads
with a single scan engine
that kind of learns from all
of these different offerings
to collectively provide higher efficacy
and higher fidelity to
malware-based threats.
And it compliments, as
Peter walked us through,
it compliments other offerings
from GuardDuty by combining
and correlating to
actually provide visibility
into the actual breed scenario,
pre-exploitation, compromise
and post-exploitation.
And this improves security operations
with contextual information
around the resources,
the malware family, the
scan engine that contributed
and the attacker information.
And that's it.
Thank you for attending this session.
I'd like to invite the fellow speakers to.